Guys the first deal changes everything and I mentioned this briefly in the last video
but I just I don't think many people understand the power of getting that first deal and I've
seen this with door-to-door sales rep I've seen this with students in this program I've
myself the game is you've got to get the first deal and whatever you can do whatever way whatever
website whatever it is that's gonna get you the first deal the quickest is the thing that you
need to do because and and I shared this as well in the last video but the saying is hey
when's the best time to get a deal when's the best time to get a sale after you got the last
one because as soon as you get the first one mentally you're completely like oh that's it
like that that's all it takes I got a thousand dollar deal all I got to do is a hundred more
of those and I'm at a hundred K a month right and something something breaks open I don't know what
it is I don't know how to describe it but something breaks open when this happens and you'll see it
more often than not people will get their first deal and it might take them they might have been
in a program for three years and got nothing they come into my program they get their first deal in
three weeks four weeks two weeks and guess what their second deal they get three days later they
get a week later they get two weeks later it's like okay what the heck it took you three years
to get your first one and it took you six days to get your second one how does that work I don't
know all I know is that momentum is a very powerful thing and when you get that first deal it's gonna
break everything open it's gonna just remove these these mental chains that you have like I can't do
this or ten thousand seems like a lot the second you get that first deal everything changes so
whatever we got to do if that means you need to pre sell maybe you have a bunch of sites you're
like oh I really don't you know as I talked about we got these sites and and you know I really don't
want to be paying for this hosting and they're good projects whatever put them to the side let's go
pre sell a deal and let's get that first one because if you get the first one and you get the
momentum selling those sites down the road now that you have the momentum now that you have the
money coming in and you're not so desperate you don't have that sales breath it's gonna change
everything okay so I just want to stress to you the importance of as you're looking at this and
as you're picking whether to go into a new project whether to use an existing site the game is how
do we get our very first deal as soon as possible because when we once we do that everything changes